step back medical kyle rittenhouse is
the teenager who took a weapon onto the
streets
as a self-styled protector this was the
moment his efforts ended in the deaths
of two people
when he was chased by a crowd and shots
were fired
earlier in the night he was captured on
camera apparently having been pepper
sprayed
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property yes
the 17 year old social media postings
show him to be a donald trump supporter
this was from his attendance at a trump
rally
he wasn't the only armed civilian on the
streets of kenosha on tuesday night
these pictures show a tense standoff
between protesters and members of the
public
militia style guarding a petrol station
the following night saw more peaceful
protest it didn't stop anthony perini
patrolling
armed from the roof of his petrol
station we're not walking around with
ak-47s and trying to look militant
we want to avoid any kind of situation
but at the end of the day
i'm a firm believer in property rights
and this is my baby
and i'm going to protect it to the best
of my ability
we went to a gun shop just over the
state line in illinois
in the current climate business is
booming
in this state there's been a five
hundred percent increase in the number
of people looking for a licence to own a
firearm
this is an ar-15 similar to the weapon
involved in tuesday's incident they say
in this gun store
this wall was full at the start of the
week now it's half empty
according to the store manager business
growth is based
on fear it's been the busiest year we've
seen in
several several years people are scared
they they're not sure what's going to
end up happening
a lot of people just want to be able to
protect themselves
they are problems and solutions at the
heart of america's election campaign we
will put out the fire we will put out
the flame we will put out
the vandalism
because the vandalism and the looting is
ridiculous
following events here in kenosha
america's top basketball stars
pause their participation in the sport's
annual playoffs
in protest at what they call police
brutality they plan to return to court
by the weekend
protest has gone quiet but it hasn't
gone away
james matthews sky news in kenosha
wisconsin